foreign
very close
my mother says her son became overcame
so many obstacles only to die at the
hands of a stranger on an RTC bus and
tonight we're hearing from the family of
that murder victim for the very first
time a new cell investigator David
charns breaking several parts of this
story including how it took four minutes
for that bus to pull over David speaking
to that family David well Brian Denise
Dominique Lucas's parents say their son
is more than a name in court documents
he's a son a brother and a friend a 30
year old man who faced challenges all
throughout his life
because I won't be so
I miss myself
here I was somebody do that to him
Shalonda Purdy and Darrell Lucas Beam
with pride as they describe their son
Dominique it was just all around goodbye
what were his aspirations he won't make
his mama Rich
both parents laughing as they remember
Dominique a son who overcame challenges
to become as independent as he could be
when he was seven a car hit him breaking
his neck it was pretty
pretty rough for him learning to do
everything again but throughout those
struggles he held a steady job taking
the bus wherever life took him what did
he say about taking the bus he didn't
mind taking the bus yeah no problem
ultimately you would be a bus ride that
would take his life
feels like the day I found it Dominique
was on his way to work on Sunday
February 26th when police say another
passenger stabbed him 33 times video
evidence in the case shows Lucas
pleading with the driver for help the
bus company says because the bus was in
the far left lane on an alternate route
the doors remain closed for four minutes
no one came to Lucas's aid for seven
these are two amazing human beings that
lost an amazing son Farhan nakvi is
representing the parents as they weigh
their options what happened was
outrageous and tragic we're here to
stand with them to find out what really
happened Dominique's parents want the
world to know their son fought to become
the young man he was taking the bus and
trusting that ride just part of his
routine if anybody here you know
Dominique Lucas
to know him is to love him
and that's it
Dominic's mother says she has seen that
video of what happened to her son as for
what's next for this family they
directed questions to nocvi who says
right now they're just investigating
trying to figure out exactly what
happened and then they will go from
there I'm David charms 8 News Now